[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Herkese merhabalar
hayatımız bir satranç tablosu gibi
Aslında her şey için bir karar veriyoruz
karar vermediğimiz anlarda bile aslında
karar vermiş durumdayız ve biz satrancı
metalurste de oynuyoruz
metaforce için farklı evrenlerden
bahsediyoruz sizlere birazdan
bahsedeceğim göstereceğim videolarını
İnsanlar bir ev elinden beri bu
evrenleri merak ediyorlardı Şu anda
görmüş olduğunuz videoda
1830'larda yapılmış bir kitabı görüyoruz
1830'larda Kitabın sayfalarını keserek
içine farklı evrenleri farklı hikayeleri
yerleştirmişler ve insanlar küçük bir
delikten o kitabın içerisindeki
hikayeleri evrenleri hayata dair
paylaşımları görüyorlar
1830'lardan
2023'lere sanal Evrenler artırılmış
gerçeklik sanal dünyaların içerisine
Hayal güçlerinin katılması dijital
ikizlerden bahsediyoruz Universe yani
gerçek dünyadayız Ama sanal ortamlarda
fabrikaların bire bir dijital İkizlerini
oluşturuyoruz içerideki makinelerin üç
boyutlu modellerini nasıl çalıştığını o
fabrikanın çalışanlarının o eğitimleri
alarak sanal gerçeklik eğitimleri alarak
line'larda o fabrikanın makinelerinde
nasıl çalışmaları gerektiğini veya fuara
gittiklerinde fuar alanlarında
müşterilerine ürünlerinin her modelini
her rengini ve kendi çalışma alanlarını
da içeride göstermek suretiyle ve tüm
bunları bir tane sanal gerçeklik
gözlüğünün içerisinde
gerçekleştirmelerini sağlıyoruz
metaforce'un bir satranç olduğunu
söylemiştim Fabrikalar sanal
üniversiteler Yani bir üniversitenin de
dijital ikizi oluşturulabilir Bir
fabrikanın oluşturulabilir dedim yeni
bir proje gayrimenkul projesi daha
herhangi bir şey yok ortada sadece
Toprak var üzerine yapılacak olan
binanın nasıl olacağını insanlara bir
sanal gerçeklik gözlüğünün içerisinde
gösterebiliyorsunuz Dolayısıyla
dünyadaki tüm sektörleri tüm her şeyi
içeriye sanal evrene alabiliyorsunuz
Tabii metabors dediğimiz zaman farklı
bir açı daha var hayal gücünüzle de
farklı evrenleri oluşturabiliyorsunuz
bir tane Evren yok milyarlarca Evren var
Samanyolu'ndaki yıldızlar kadar sanal
evrenlerimiz var hayal gücünü sizin
sınırlarınızı tespit ediyor Dolayısıyla
bu Meta ortamda bir yol çizmemiz
gerekiyordu ne olur izlememiz lazım
hangi alanda başlamak ve devam etmek
lazım diye düşündüğümüzde biz sağlık
alanını tercih ettik ve özellikle de
çocuklarımızı çocuklarımıza yönelik
çalışmalar yapmak istedik
çocuklarımızla ilgili çalışırken
artırılmış gerçeklik tabanlı
QR kodunu telefonla taradığında buradan
3 boyutlu modellerin bulundukları ortama
gelmesini sağlayan çalışmalara imza
attık
şöyle bir bakacak olursak yapay zeka ile
oluşturulmuş görsellerimizi görüyorsunuz
astronotları kelebekleri yunusları
Vücudumuzu tanıyalım köşesinde o
organlarımızın nasıl olduğunu
hayvanlarımızı gezegenlerimizi onların
bulunduğu ortama getiriyoruz dediğim
gibi Yapay Zeka Temelli olarak
görsellerini oluşturuyoruz ellerinde bir
kart var O kartın arkada yüzünde de
belli yazılar var Bunları da
okuyabiliyorlar yani gerçek dünyadalar
fiziki ürünler var telefonlarıyla da bu
QR kodlarını taradıklarında dediğim gibi
bu astronotları palyaçoları
gezegenleri onların bulunduğu ortama
getiriyoruz sağlık alanında çalışıyoruz
dedim onkoloji hastası çocuklarımız
lösemili çocuklarımızda İstanbul Tıp
Fakültesi'nde bu çocuklarımızın
bulundukları uzun süre yattıkları hasta
odalarına palyaçoları getiriyoruz
hayvanlar getiriyoruz ellerinde kelebek
konduruyoruz ve hayatlarına bir pozitif
etki artı değer sağlamaya çalışıyoruz
Bunun dışında bunların kitaplarını
gerçekleştirdik kitaplarda da deprem
tatbikatı gezegenler uzay turu Yani
aslında bulundukları ortamdan onları
farklı bir evrene götürecek ve
hayatlarına dediğim gibi bir artı değer
sağlayacak kitap çalışmalarımız var Hem
bu alanda çalışan geçmişteki bilim
insanlarını gösteriyoruz kendilerine hem
de bu okudukları iki boyutları kitabı 3
boyuta çekmek Dolayısıyla ortamda
onların dolaşmasını ve bulundukları
ortama o ürünlerin 3 boyutlu olarak
gelmesini sağlıyoruz
Kelebek Etkisi Aslında bir anlamda
Kelebek Etkisi Birisi bir noktada bir
hareket yapar ve çok uzak bir noktadaki
insanın da
etkilenmesini sağlar bu yaptığı etki
fizikçi Einstein ne demiş bütün her şey
atomlardan oluşuyor elektronlardan
oluşuyor bu elektronların hareketleri
ile titreşim oluşuyor Bu titreşimler
düşüncelerimizi oluşturuyor ve bu
düşüncelerde hareketlerimizi etkiliyor
National Geographic fotoğrafçısı
Afrika'ya gidiyor zanzi barda dijital
telefonuyla dijital fotoğraflarını
çekiyor bizimle paylaşıyor Biz o
fotoğrafların yapay zekayla nft'ye
çevrilmesini sağlıyoruz sanal gerçeklik
ortamında bir sergi salonu hazırlıyoruz
bunun aynı zamanda telefonla çalışan
versiyonu olan artırılmış gerçeklikle de
bir sergi salonu olmasını sağlıyoruz
uzun süre yatan çocuklarımızın o
zanzibardaki çekilmiş fotoğrafların
sergi salonunda dolaşmasını sağlıyoruz
hep bilirsiniz hastanede yattığınız
zaman çıkarın beni bu hastaneden
laflarını bu sanal gerçeklik gözlüğü ile
bulundukları ortamdan farklı bir ortama
ışınlanmalarını sağlıyoruz Bu bazen bir
uzay gemisinin içi bazen bir sergi
salonu bazen bir konser salonu bazen de
bir tıp fakültesinde sanal bir
ameliyathane Tıp Fakültesi
öğrencilerimiz için gerçekleştirmiş
olduğumuz sanal ameliyathane projemizi
görüyorsunuz Burada da öğrencilerimiz bu
gözlükleri takmak suretiyle birdenbire
bu ortamı görmüyorlar sanal bir
ameliyathane ortamına ışınlanıyorlar ve
ortamda bir tane anestezi altında olan
hastamız var Hastanın Kalp Damar
Cerrahisi ile ilgili ameliyatını
yapıyorlar veya tiroid ameliyatını
gerçekleştiriyorlar ortamda ne makine
var ne sarf malzeme var ne hasta var ama
İstedikleri zaman istedikleri kadar
istedikleri yerde bu operasyonları
deneyimleyerek bu ameliyatla ilgili
tecrübe kazanmalarını sağlıyoruz
Dünyanın bir ucunda bir kişi hasta
oluyor
sonra o hastalık yayılmaya başlıyor
kendi ülkemize geliyor ülkemizden başka
ülkelere doğru da yayılıyor hastalık
sayısı artıyor ölüm rakamları artıyor o
hastayı muayene etmesi gereken doktor
var testlerini yapması gereken sağlık
profesyonelleri var bu deneyleri
testleri nasıl yapacaklarını sanal
ortamda öğretiyoruz o hastayı nasıl
muayene etmesi gerekiyor Hangi şartları
uygulaması gerekiyor kendisini de
korumak hastayı da korumak ve diğer
insanları da koruması açısından sanal
ameliyathaneden sonra sanal deneyle
laboratuvarını gerçekleştirdik ve tüm
hastalarımız için
hekimlerimizin eğitimine yönelik sağlık
alanındaki test denemelerini sanal
ortamda yapmalarını sağlayacak sanal
deneyle laboratuvarı çalışmasını yaptık
bu önemli bir hamlemizdi Çünkü Tıp
Fakültesi
hekimle Öğrencinin bir arada olmasını
gerektiren uygulamalı eğitim gerektiren
bir husus öğrencilerimiz pandemi
döneminde evlerindeydiler herhangi bir
uygulama yapamıyorlardı sanal ortamda Bu
çalışmaları deneyimlemek suretiyle
eğitimlerine katkı sağladık Evet sağlık
alanında ilerliyoruz sağlık alanında
üretim yapan firmalarımız da var bu
sağlıkla ilgili ürünleri dünyaya da
duyurmak gerekiyor sanal ortamda bir
alışveriş yapılmasını sağlayan ihracata
katkı sağlayacak olan bir Merkez
tasarladık burada görmüş olduğunuz tüm
mağazaların içerisinde ürünleri 3
boyutlu olarak inceleyebiliyorsunuz bu
İncelediğiniz ürünlerle ilgili toptan
Siparişinizi geçebiliyorsunuz
Dolayısıyla bu çalışmayı müşterinizi
Hollanda'da Eğer bu görüşmeyi
yaptıysanız İstanbul'daki fabrikanın
üretime geçmesini gerçek zamanlı olarak
sağlayabiliyorsunuz
uzun süre hastanede yatıyor çocuklarımız
dedik hepimizin başına gelebilir ve Bizi
buradan çıkart dedikleri noktada uzay
gemisinin içerisinde uzaya gönderiyoruz
o uzaya da gezerken Tüm gezegenlerin
arasından geçiriyoruz ardından sanal bir
başka bir gezegene varıyorlar rotameta
evrenine varıyorlar ve rotameta evrenin
içerisinde de bir sanal sergi salonu var
hem nfteleri dolaşabiliyorlar hem de
gerçek dijital fotoğrafların sergi
salonunu dolaşabilmekteler bu sergi
salonun içerisine heykellerde
konulabilir fotoğraflar konulabilir
videolar keza konulabilir
metaforce bir satranç demiştim ya
insanların bakış açılarına gelelim arsa
mı satın alıyoruz hocam diye soruyorlar
Hayır bir sarsı satmıyoruz hocam
diyorlar gözlüğü taktığımız zaman işte
dijital hep alıştık sabit kalıyoruz kilo
almaya sebep olacak hareketsizliğe neden
olacak ama bir taraftan da yerinden
kalkamayan Farklı ortamlara gidemeyen
Dolayısıyla spor yapma egzersiz yapması
gereken kişiler var Ve bu sanal
gerçeklik gözlüğü ile sanal spor
merkezlerinde beyzbol oynamalarını
futbol oynamalarını isterlerse
bulutların üzerinde isterlerse bir
kütüphanenin içerisinde dart atmalarını
tenis oynamalarını pinpon oynamalarını
aynı zamanda bunları oynarken de vücut
değerlerini de toplamak suretiyle ne
kadar kalori harcadıklarını oksijen
satürasyon Ateş nabız gibi Vital
değerlerinde toplayıp kişiye özel analiz
yapılmasını sağlıyoruz
başarı dediğimiz şey herkese göre
değişiyor Kimisi çok para kazanmanın
başarı olduğunu düşünür Kimisi altın
madalya almanın başarılı olmanın gereği
olduğunu düşünür Kimisi ise bir
başkasının yüzünde bir küçük
gülümsemenin oluştuğunu görmek başarının
gerçekleştiğini düşündürür Rabia kızımız
olimpiyatlarda bizi temsil eden bir
okçumuz
çok fazla egzersiz yapmış ardından da
kas yırtığı oluşuyor eline ok
almayacaksın diyor fizyoterapisti ama
Rabia çok üzgün Çünkü Türkiye
Şampiyonasına hazırlanıyor kas yırtığı
var performans düşüklüğünden korkuyor
nişan alışından
etkileneceğinden korkuyor ve bizimle
buluşuyor ardından sanal ortamda o
katmak suretiyle tüm test denemelerini
içeride egzersizlerini gerçekleştiriyor
ve yine Türkiye şampiyonasında ikincilik
ödülü almak suretiyle hiçbir performans
düşüklüğü olmadan
madalyaya layık görülüyor Biz de onun
Yüzündeki Bir küçük gülümseme ile
dünyalar bizim oluyor ve başardığımımızı
bu Satrançta doğru bir hamle attığımızı
bize düşündürüyor
hayatta akıp gidiyor Bir taraftan da
Yıllar ne çabuk geçiyor
Ben şöyle bir sormak istiyorum salonda
Meta virüsü daha önce duymuş olanlar el
kaldırabilirler mi
harika sanal gerçekliği duydunuz o zaman
onları bir görebilir miyim
süper artırılmış gerçeklik
Peki bunu deneyimleyen var mı sanal
gerçeklik gözlüğünü taktım ve ben burada
gerçekten bu sanal evrenleri
deneyimledim
çok güzel baya Eller kalkıyor
Bodrum Marmara koleji'ndekileri
kutluyorum Çünkü bunu deneyimleyemeyen
ve bu oyunları oynayamayan veya bu
dersleri alamayan bu teknolojinin
varlığından haberdar olmayan çok büyük
bir kesim var Bunları Anlatmaya
çalışıyoruz buradaki yaptığımız
çalışmaların dünyada ses getirdiğini de
söylemek istiyorum
dünyadaki 15 Dijital Teknoloji
şirketinden birisi olarak seçildik
burada yaptığımız çalışmaları dünyaya
duyurmanın yanı sıra deminki O
oyuncumuzun sporcumuzun yüzündeki
gülümseme başarılarına artı değer
sağlama hastanede yatan hastaların
hastaneden erken çıkmalarına sebep
olacak o egzersizleri yaptırma ve
sporcuların yetişmesine katkıda bulunma
Bir taraftan da uzun süre hastanede
kalan çocuklarımızın mutlu olmasını
sağlamaya yönelik çalışmalarımız var
yıllar hızlı akıyor dedim
Babamın bir sözü var der ki anam beni
bir daha doğurmaz
bu beni çok etkilemişti
iç motivasyon diyoruz ya işte o iç
motivasyon Anam beni bir daha doğurmaz
lafından geliyor bende
son noktaya gittiğimde ölüm de
şeyindeyken keşke yapsaydım dememek
istiyorum o yüzden de yapmak istediğim
hayallerimin arkasından koşuyorum
sizlere de aynı şekilde gençler Lütfen
hayallerinizi bir yere de yerinde
bırakmayın Asla Pes etmeyin hayal edin
gerçekten gerçek oluyor Türkiye'de de
oluyor dünyada da olur Ama burada da
oluyorun altını çizmek istiyorum ve
atatürkümüzün bir sözüyle konuşmamı
tamamlamak istiyorum kadınlarımız için
asıl mücadele alanı asıl Zafer
kazanılması gereken alan biçim ve
kılıkta başarıdan çok ışıkla bilgi ve
kültürle gerçek vasil faziletle süslenip
donanmaktır beni dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]